This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here's someone you should know. Julie Shapiro, I'm Executive Producer of Radio Topia. And we're going to talk about Showcase. Showcase is a new project from Radio Topia and the first series in Showcase, and really the whole concept of Showcase,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是Roman Mars。这是你应该认识的人。Julie Shapiro，我是RadioTopia的执行制片人。我们要聊聊《Showcase》。《Showcase》是RadioTopia的一个新项目，也是《Showcase》系列中的第一个系列，实际上，整个《Showcase》的概念，
happens to make a good 99% Invisible story. So I asked Julie to come talk to me about it. And this is very much your project that you're experiencing. So can you tell us a little bit about Showcase and how it serves the mission of radiotopia? Sure. Well, Showcase directly came out of our experience with PodQuest, which we ran about a year ago,
恰好构成了一个很棒的《99% Invisible》故事。所以我请Julie来跟我聊聊它。这很大程度上是你正在经历的项目。那么你能给我们介绍一下《Showcase》以及它是如何服务于RadioTopia的使命的吗？当然。嗯，《Showcase》直接源于我们大约一年前开展的PodQuest项目的经验，
where we invited anyone and everyone to submit podcast ideas about whatever they were interested and are wanted to make a podcast about. And we got over 1,500 entries and we chose one. It was called Ear Hustle. It's now a show in radiotopia. But it's the thing that I'm- Incredibly popular show in the video talk.
当时我们邀请了所有人提交关于他们感兴趣或想制作的播客想法。我们收到了超过1500份参赛作品，我们选择了其中一个。它叫《Ear Hustle》。它现在是RadioTopia的一个节目。但这是我……在RadioTopia中非常受欢迎的节目。
Yeah, it's a show we're very, very proud of and amazed at the response it's been getting, et cetera. But the point was we had so many great ideas, but they weren't all necessarily sustainable long-term show ideas and thought, well, what if radio topia could get behind a podcast that featured all of these different ideas one after another? Without them being separate podcasts that had to go out and gain their own audience and
是的，这是一个我们非常、非常引以为豪的节目，对它所获得的反响感到惊讶，等等。但重点是，我们有太多很棒的想法，但它们不一定都是可持续的长期节目想法，于是我想，如果RadioTopia能支持一个播客，一个接一个地呈现所有这些不同的想法会怎样？它们不必是需要自己去获取受众并
live on their own, how could we use the radio topia name and reputation to help support even more producers with different kinds of ideas that wouldn't be ongoing shows. And so what showcase is, is one podcast that has limited run series one after another, with short breaks in between. And these will be shows of all stripes. We're really going to play with form, play with topics, push boundaries, give new producers a chance and really see how we can provide really high quality listening for our audiences.
独立生存的单独播客，我们该如何利用RadioTopia的名字和声誉来帮助支持更多拥有不同想法的制作人，而这些想法又不是持续性的节目呢？所以《Showcase》就是一个播客，它一个接一个地推出有限的系列节目，中间有短暂的休息。这些节目将是各种各样的。我们真的会玩转形式，玩转主题，突破界限，给新制作人机会，并真正看看我们如何能为我们的听众提供高质量的收听体验。
How do you conceive of something that sort of sticks together, holds together enough to be a radio-topia show or kind of represent our values in a certain way, but also be disparate enough to make this an experiment worth having? I'm just looking for ideas that I know, like I'm interested in automatically. I haven't heard anything like that before, but the producers kind of fit the radiotopia profile. They're independent, they're highly ambitious.
你是如何构思出一种既能保持一致性，足以成为一个RadioTopia节目或以某种方式代表我们的价值观，同时又足够分散，使之成为一个值得进行的实验的东西的呢？我只是在寻找我知道我自动会感兴趣的想法。我以前从未听过类似的东西，但制作人有点符合RadioTopia的形象。他们是独立的，非常有抱负。
They have big ideas about the subject that they're bringing to my attention, but they have a sense of humor and they can play a little bit, and they're sound inclined. I think every pitch I'm considering right now has a lot of sound involved because that's really a hallmark of a lot of radio topia shows. This is careful crafting, again, how to experiment with the form, how to hear from new voices.
他们对自己带到我面前的主题有宏大的想法，但他们有幽默感，可以玩一点，而且他们对声音很敏感。我认为我目前考虑的每一个提案都涉及很多声音，因为这确实是许多RadioTopia节目的标志。这是精心的制作，再次强调，如何尝试这种形式，如何听到新的声音。
So part of it is like what are topics we haven't heard yet, you know, go in those directions and also just encourage people to like really come up with something brand new original. Something we can take a bit of a risk on because the reward is going to be in trying something new and giving listeners a new listening experience. Yeah, so this is going to be the type of podcast for the adventurous listener and will reward that type of person. And so I'm going to just do this in put my 9.9.pi hat on
所以部分原因是，我们还没听过哪些主题，你知道，朝着这些方向去，同时也鼓励人们真正想出一些全新的、原创的东西。我们可以冒一点险的东西，因为回报将在于尝试新事物并给听众一种新的收听体验。是的，所以这将是为爱冒险的听众准备的那种播客，并将奖励那种类型的人。所以我要戴上我的9.9.pi帽子，
as it, from a design perspective. Why all one podcast, like through this format, what type of experience are you trying to shape and cultivate with the audience? It's a really good question because we also talked about all of these series just being separate podcasts. There's some liability here.
从设计的角度来看。为什么全部放在一个播客里，通过这种格式，你试图与听众塑造和培养什么样的体验？这是一个非常好的问题，因为我们也讨论过所有这些系列是否应该作为单独的播客。这里面有一些风险。
Will people stick with it from one to the next? But I really hope, you know, the through line for all of these series is going to be an original radio topy and sense of surprise and quality, and no matter what the topic is, hopefully people will tune in. And, you know, people thinking of it as a showcase experience, not just thinking about the series that comes up next, but really having this like comprehensive sense of what this offering is from radio tovia. Right, I mean, that's the thing I like about it,
人们会从一个系列坚持到下一个系列吗？但我真的希望，你知道，所有这些系列的主线将是原创的RadioTopia式的惊喜感和质量，无论主题是什么，希望人们都会收听。而且，你知道，人们把它当作一种《Showcase》体验，不仅仅是考虑下一个系列，而是真正对RadioTopia提供的这种产品有一个全面的认识。对，我的意思是，这就是我喜欢它的地方，
because there's something about this where, you know, hopefully you get a little further into it to judge, you know, because you trust the idea of the channel. Like, it means something to be a listener to showcase. And so, I'm just really intrigued by the new type of listening that might come out of that that isn't based around building a hit around a single podcast.
因为这里面有些东西，你知道，希望你能更深入地去评判，你知道，因为你信任这个频道的理念。就像，成为《Showcase》的听众意味着什么。所以，我真的对可能从中产生的那种新的收听方式很感兴趣，它不是基于围绕单个播客打造热门节目。
You know, we talk about radio topia as a kind of music label a lot. And so this is kind of like a compilation record, LP, CD. Like our seven-inch series. And so, you know, you've obviously have a few lined up. Like, I don't want to spoil anything, but can you sort of talk, you know, generally, about the types of shows that are going to be on? We're going to kick off with a very sort of essayistic, sound-rich series about listening
你知道，我们经常把RadioTopia比作一种唱片公司。所以这有点像合辑唱片、LP、CD。就像我们的七英寸唱片系列。所以，你知道，你显然已经排好了几个。就像，我不想剧透任何东西，但你能大致谈谈将要播出的节目类型吗？我们将以一个非常散文式、声音丰富的系列开始，关于数字时代的聆听。
in the digital age. How listening has shifted for us through analog technology, changing into transforming into digital technology. And this was proposed by musician Damon Krakowski, who was in a band that I used to love, Galaxy 500, and then Damon and Damon. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah, so I had to get over that to begin with when we started talking to him. But, you know, I have an ex-girlfriend who's going to be very impressed by that.
聆听如何通过模拟技术转变为数字技术而为我们发生了改变。这是由音乐家Damon Krakowski提出的，他曾是我过去非常喜欢的乐队Galaxy 500的成员，还有Damon and Damon。哦，真的吗？是的，是的，所以当我们开始和他交谈时，我首先得克服这一点。但是，你知道，我有一个前女友会对这个印象深刻。
Oh, I can't wait for her to hear this. Make sure she gives us a rating on iTunes, please. So, so Damon, this is a perfect example. He's actually wrote a book about this in the past year, and we were talking about how it had to be a podcast. It was about listening, shifting from analog to digital culture. How would you represent that through sound? And in a way that people could understand it wouldn't be too technical, wouldn't be too intellectualized. But how does he convey how lives are changing through these
哦，我迫不及待想让她听到这个。请确保她在iTunes上给我们评分。所以，所以Damon，这是一个完美的例子。他实际上在过去一年里写了一本关于这个的书，我们当时在讨论它如何必须成为一个播客。它是关于聆听，从模拟文化转向数字文化。你如何通过声音来表现这一点？以一种人们能理解的方式，不会太技术化，不会太知识分子化。但他如何传达生活是如何通过这些
technological shifts? And so he came up with six different episodes. They're sort of based on the book. But it's really departed from the book and become its own engines called Ways of Hearing. And that's what we're gonna kick off the showcase with. And I think there couldn't be a better starter series because it's really about how we listen,
技术转变而改变的呢？所以他想出了六个不同的剧集。它们有点基于那本书。但它确实脱离了那本书，成为了它自己的引擎，叫做《Ways of Hearing》。这就是我们将要开启《Showcase》的内容。我认为没有比这更好的开篇系列了，因为它确实是关于我们如何聆听，
how we listen in this age. And I really wanna get people engaged with their ears and thinking about, you know, what is it about podcasting that they respond to? This is Ways of Hearing, listening in the digital age from radio topia showcase. The first record I made was all analog. It wasn't a choice. That's just how it was done in the 80s.
我们在这个时代如何聆听。我真的想让人们用耳朵参与进来，思考，你知道，播客吸引他们的是什么？这是《Ways of Hearing》，来自RadioTopia《Showcase》的数字时代聆听。我制作的第一张唱片全是模拟的。这不是一种选择。80年代就是这么做的。
My friends and I lived in an all-analog world. There were no computers in our lives. That didn't feel weird. It would have been weird if there had been. At the time, computers were something you saw on TV during a moonshot. You saw people sitting at computers at NASA mission control. Making a record wasn't anything like a moonshot. It didn't use numbers.
我和我的朋友们生活在一个全模拟的世界里。我们的生活中没有电脑。那感觉并不奇怪。如果有的话才会奇怪。当时，电脑是你在登月期间在电视上看到的东西。你看到人们坐在NASA任务控制中心的电脑前。制作唱片一点也不像登月。它不使用数字。
It didn't use data. Not that there was no technology involved. The tape decks, mixing board, microphones, they all seemed very magical. But they were made of magnets, gears, motors, electricity, like all the mechanical objects in our lives then. And so, my bandmates and I set up our instruments in the studio. We counted off, and we played our songs. In many ways, it's simply nostalgia to think that it was so different. People are people, sounds or sounds, and our technology is always changing. Still, there's something particular about that analog experience, which seems hard to conjure
它不使用数据。并不是说没有涉及技术。磁带录音机、调音台、麦克风，它们看起来都非常神奇。但它们是由磁铁、齿轮、电机、电力制成的，就像当时我们生活中的所有机械物体一样。所以，我和我的乐队成员在录音室里架好了乐器。我们倒数，然后演奏了我们的歌。在很多方面，认为它如此不同纯粹是怀旧。人就是人，声音就是声音，我们的技术总是在变化。尽管如此，那种模拟体验还是有一些特别之处，似乎很难在
back up in the digital present. And for that very reason, which seems hard to conjure back up in the digital pressup. And for that very reason, there was a feeling when the tape started rolling, that this was the moment we would capture, a feeling of time moving both more slowly and more quickly than usual. Like when you're in an accident, each split second is suddenly so palpable as if you're living in slow motion. Yet what do we say when it's over? It all happened in an instant. Analog recording is like an accident in other ways. On tape, there was no undo.
数字时代重现。正是因为这个原因，似乎很难在数字时代重现。正是因为这个原因，当磁带开始转动时，有一种感觉，这就是我们将要捕捉的时刻，一种时间移动得比平时更慢也更快的错觉。就像当你发生事故时，每一秒钟突然变得如此明显，仿佛你生活在慢动作中。然而，当它结束时我们说什么？这一切都发生在一瞬间。模拟录音在其他方面也像一场事故。在磁带上，没有撤销。
You could try again if you had the time and money. But you couldn't move backwards. What's done is done for better and worse. Today, life as a musician is very different. In the digital studio, and I'm using one now, everything you do is professional. That is, it can be redone, reshaped, rebuilt. There's no commitment, because each element of recording can be endlessly changed. It can even be conjured from digital scratch, as it were, and entered into a computer directly as data
如果你有时间和金钱，你可以再试一次。但你不能倒退。做了就是做了，无论好坏。今天，作为音乐家的生活非常不同。在数字录音室里，我现在就在用一个，你所做的一切都是专业的。也就是说，它可以重做、重塑、重建。没有承诺，因为录音的每个元素都可以无休止地改变。它甚至可以从数字零开始，可以说是直接作为数据输入电脑，
without anyone performing at all. This means there's no moment from lived experience that is captured forever and unalterably so in the digital studio. Which is why it's more than nostalgia that makes me remember the analog studio as different than what we know today. Because the digital era has not just altered our tools for working with sound, or image, or moving images, it is changing our relationship to time itself. This is Ways of Hearing, a six-part podcast from videotopias Showcase exploring the nature of listening in our digital world.
而无需任何人表演。这意味着在数字录音室里，没有一个来自生活体验的时刻被永远且不可更改地捕捉下来。这就是为什么让我认为模拟录音室与我们今天所知的不同，不仅仅是怀旧。因为数字时代不仅改变了我们处理声音、图像或动态图像的工具，它还在改变我们与时间本身的关系。这是《Ways of Hearing》，来自RadioTopia《Showcase》的六集播客，探索我们数字世界中聆听的本质。
I'm Damon Krueckowski, a musician and a writer. In each episode, we'll look at a different way that the switch from analog to digital audio is changing our perceptions of time, of space, of love, money, and power. This is about sound. The medium we're sharing together now. But I'm worried about the quality of that sharing, because we don't seem to be listening to each other very well right now in the world. Our voices carry further than they ever did before, thanks to digital media. But how are they being heard?
我是Damon Krueckowski，一名音乐家和作家。在每一集中，我们将审视从模拟音频到数字音频的转换如何改变我们对时间、空间、爱、金钱和权力的感知。这是关于声音。我们现在正在共享的媒介。但我担心这种共享的质量，因为在这个世界上，我们似乎现在并没有很好地倾听彼此。多亏了数字媒体，我们的声音传得比以往任何时候都远。但它们是如何被听到的呢？
Episode 1, A ton. Musicians know time is flexible. Classical players call this tempo rubato, Italian for stolen time. You steal a bit here, give a bit back there. Jazz players call it swing. Rock and funk players call it groove. This flexibility of time is something we're all familiar with, whether or not we play an instrument. There's the time it takes for dawn to arrive while you lay awake after a nightmare.
第一集，节奏。音乐家知道时间是灵活的。古典乐手称之为tempo rubato，意大利语意为“偷来的时间”。你在这里偷一点，在那里还一点。爵士乐手称之为摇摆（swing）。摇滚和放克乐手称之为律动（groove）。这种时间的灵活性是我们大家都熟悉的，无论我们是否演奏乐器。有你在噩梦醒来后躺着等待黎明到来的时间。
And there's the time it takes when you're out all night with your friends. What musicians terms like rubato, swing, and groove acknowledge is that time is experienced, not counted like a clock. And our experience of time is variable, it's always changing. Even if our eyes look at a clock and see 12 equal hours, our ears are ready to steal a bit here, give a bit back there. In the analog media we use to reproduce sound, records and tapes reflect this variable sense of time, a time that's elastic.
也有你和朋友整晚出去玩的时间。音乐家们用rubato、swing和groove等术语承认的是，时间是体验出来的，而不是像时钟那样计算出来的。我们对时间的体验是可变的，它总是在变化。即使我们的眼睛看着时钟看到12个相等的小时，我们的耳朵也准备好在这里偷一点，在那里还一点。在我们用来重现声音的模拟媒体中，唱片和磁带反映了这种可变的时间感，一种有弹性的时间。
The first turntables, Vectrolis, were hand cranked. You wound up a spring which spun the platter as it wound down. The speed was hardly steady, at least never for long. At the opposite end of the 20th century, hip-hop DJs used speed controls on turntables to change the tempo of a record, to match it to another and keep the groove going, or in the studio to pile up samples from older records and make a new one. In 1990, a tribe called Quest sampled the bass from walk on the wild side, along with the surface noise from the LP, added it to a drum loop from Alonni Smith LP and made a
第一台唱机，Vectrolis，是手摇的。你上紧发条，发条在松开时旋转唱盘。速度几乎不稳，至少从来没有持续过。在20世纪的另一端，嘻哈DJ使用唱机上的速度控制来改变唱片的速度，将其与另一张唱片匹配并保持律动，或者在录音室里堆叠来自旧唱片的采样并制作一张新唱片。1990年，A Tribe Called Quest采样了《Walk on the Wild Side》中的贝斯，连同LP的表面噪音，将其添加到一个来自Alonni Smith LP的鼓循环中，并制作了一个
new hit out of it. They also had to give up on collecting any royalties. One of the biggest samples that we were able to clear was the walk on the wild side by Lou Reed and by clearing that he just took 100% of that song. Wait, really? He did. Wow. What you're saying, Lou Reed gets 100%.
新的热门歌曲。他们也不得不放弃收取任何版税。我们能够清除的最大采样之一是Lou Reed的《Walk on the Wild Side》，通过清除它，他直接拿走了那首歌的100%。等等，真的吗？他确实拿了。哇。你的意思是，Lou Reed拿了100%。
That's Ali Shaheed Muhammad from a tribe called Quest and Franny Kelly. They host a podcast about hip-hop called Microphone Check. Yeah, that's his song. Ali, I always thought, you know, my band Gax 500, we ripped off the Velvet Underground way more than you did. We didn't have to pay them a dime. I asked Ali how Tribe used the variable speed of turn tables to make their own records. No, sometimes we would change the speed on a turntable
那是来自A Tribe Called Quest的Ali Shaheed Muhammad和Franny Kelly。他们主持一个关于嘻哈的播客，叫《Microphone Check》。是的，那是他的歌。Ali，我一直认为，你知道，我的乐队Galaxy 500，我们抄袭Velvet Underground的程度比你们多得多。我们一分钱都没付给他们。我问Ali，Tribe是如何利用唱机的变速来制作他们自己的唱片的。不，有时我们会改变唱机上的速度，
because the staple hip-hop turntable is the techniques 1200 and so that has a pitch control when we would sometimes pitch it high there. Sometimes a 33 RPM record, you put it on 45. And one thing with Tribe, we layered certain sounds and so you kind of had to pitch them because often they weren't in the same key. Layering these sounds, a Tribe called Quest discovered something else about their samples. The records we were recording, they might not have been playing to a metronome, and it were free-flowing, so there are moments within, let's say, even a two-bar phrase that maybe a drummer or a bass player, like, were aligned in the first two bars, and the tempo seemed
因为嘻哈的标准唱机是Technics 1200，所以它有一个音高控制，我们有时会把它调高。有时一张33转的唱片，你把它放在45转上。Tribe的一件事是，我们分层了某些声音，所以你必须调整它们的音高，因为它们通常不在同一个调上。分层这些声音，A Tribe Called Quest发现了关于他们采样的另一件事。我们录制的唱片，它们可能不是跟着节拍器演奏的，而且是自由流动的，所以即使在两小节的乐句中，也可能有一个鼓手或贝斯手，比如，在前两小节是对齐的，节奏似乎
to be consistent, and then the last three beats of a bar, it sped up a slow down. In 1988, the songs my bandmates and I recorded slowed down and sped up just like Ali Shaheed described. I know because I was the drummer. We played as steadily as we could, but this was a performance. We were nervous and excited and we sped up at the chorus. You might find that a flaw in our recordings, or you might feel it's a part of their charm. Musicians have been speeding up at the chorus for as long I'm sure as there have been choruses. Our experience of time is flexible. I'm sure as there have been choruses. Our experience of time is flexible. But not long after we recorded that first Galaxy 500 album, the commercial music world, for the most part, decided that this was most definitely a flaw. Bands on major labels,
是一致的，然后在一小节的最后三拍，它加速或减速了。1988年，我和我的乐队成员录制的歌曲就像Ali Shaheed描述的那样减速和加速。我知道，因为我是鼓手。我们尽可能稳定地演奏，但这是一种表演。我们很紧张也很兴奋，我们在副歌部分加速了。你可能会认为这是我们录音中的一个缺陷，或者你可能会觉得这是它们魅力的一部分。只要有副歌，音乐家们就会在副歌部分加速。我们对时间的体验是灵活的。只要有副歌，我相信就是这样。我们对时间的体验是灵活的。但在我们录制那张第一张Galaxy 500专辑后不久，商业音乐界在很大程度上决定这绝对是一个缺陷。大唱片公司的乐队，
even bands who came out of our DIY indie scene started recording to a click track that is a metronome. Fashions in music come and go. At the time everyone was also using the swirling effect called a flanger. No one remembers why. But the click track proved more than a fad. It was a change that stuck. Because what truly changed in popular music during the 1980s was that digital machines entered the mix for the first time. And machines have a different sense of time. The first drum machines to be widely used in commercial recordings were introduced in 1980.
甚至那些出自我们DIY独立场景的乐队也开始对着点击音轨录音，也就是节拍器。音乐时尚来来去去。当时每个人也都在使用一种叫镶边器（flanger）的旋转效果。没人记得为什么。但点击音轨证明不仅仅是一种时尚。这是一个坚持下来的变化。因为20世纪80年代流行音乐中真正改变的是数字机器第一次进入了混音。而机器有一种不同的时间感。第一批广泛用于商业录音的鼓机是在1980年推出的。
And MIDI, musical instrument digital interface, the language machines used to share musical information with one another, was launched in 1983. Together, these tools can lock musical time to a clock, which doesn't speed up at the chorus. course. When Galaxy 500 recorded, we played our songs in what audio engineers now refer to as real time. Real time, as the name implies, is lived time. Time is we experience it in the analog world. Digital time is not lived time. It's machine time. It's locked to a clock. And that clock, a time code, makes everything more regular than live time. Time in the digital studio is stored in discrete cells on a grid, like figures on a spreadsheet.
而MIDI，乐器数字接口，机器用来相互共享音乐信息的语言，是在1983年推出的。这些工具加在一起，可以将音乐时间锁定到一个时钟上，它不会在副歌部分加速。当Galaxy 500录音时，我们以音频工程师现在所说的实时（real time）演奏我们的歌曲。实时，顾名思义，就是生活时间。时间是我们在这个模拟世界中体验到的。数字时间不是生活时间。它是机器时间。它被锁定到一个时钟上。而那个时钟，一个时间码，使一切都比生活时间更规律。数字录音室里的时间存储在网格上的离散单元中，就像电子表格上的数字一样。
And if you've ever worked with a spreadsheet, you know those cells can be sorted any which way, and re-figured to most any desired outcome. What this means is that a given experience of digital time is only one among many equally plausible experiences. Take this podcast you're listening to. Since this is a digital medium, you could choose to hurry me up without changing the pitch of my voice, seemingly without changing any of my words or pronunciation, which means I can be equally fast speaking at 1.5 times my normal pace like a manic, or I can be equally slow speaking at three-quarters normal pace, like I'm drunk. Neither need be how this happened in real time.
如果你曾经使用过电子表格，你就知道那些单元格可以以任何方式排序，并重新计算出大多数任何想要的结果。这意味着对数字时间的特定体验只是众多同样合理的体验之一。以你正在听的这个播客为例。由于这是一种数字媒介，你可以选择加快我的语速而不改变我声音的音高，似乎不改变我的任何单词或发音，这意味着我可以像个疯子一样以1.5倍的正常语速说话，或者我可以像喝醉了一样以四分之三的正常语速说话。这两种情况都不必是它在实时中发生的方式。
In fact, none of this need ever have happened in the sense that we understood that term in 1988. That's a track made entirely by software. The singer is a program made by Yamaha called Vocaloid. Vocaloid tracks have been cropping up on the Japanese pop charts for a number of years and are now making their way into other forms of music around the world. As for podcasts, Adobe is developing a program called VOCO that will read text aloud for you in your own voice. What could possibly go wrong? Making time conform to machines, making it regular, would seem to make it more unified,
事实上，这一切都不必发生，按照我们在1988年理解的那个术语。那是一首完全由软件制作的曲目。歌手是一个由Yamaha制作的程序，叫Vocaloid。Vocaloid曲目多年来一直出现在日本流行音乐排行榜上，现在正进入世界各地的其他音乐形式。至于播客，Adobe正在开发一个叫VOCO的程序，它会用你自己的声音为你朗读文本。可能会出什么问题呢？让时间服从机器，让它变得规律，似乎会使它变得更统一，
like a standardized timeline that any of us can tap into at any moment. But there's a surprising twist to digital time. It's actually very difficult to synchronize. It's a challenge in digital recording to line up the different layers that make up a song. If you play a guitar into a digital recorder and then play it back and add singing,
就像一个我们可以随时接入的标准化时间线。但数字时间有一个令人惊讶的转折。它实际上非常难以同步。在数字录音中对齐构成歌曲的不同层是一个挑战。如果你对着数字录音机弹奏吉他，然后回放并添加演唱，
your voice won't line up with the music exactly the way you performed it. The reason is what's called latency. Latency is the lag in digital communications introduced by the time it takes a computer to process them. Computers move very fast. That's what computers are good at. But analog time, it seems, moves faster.
你的声音将不会完全按照你表演的方式与音乐对齐。原因就是所谓的延迟（latency）。延迟是数字通信中因电脑处理它们所需的时间而引入的滞后。电脑移动得非常快。那是电脑擅长的地方。但模拟时间，似乎移动得更快。
Let's consider an example from outside music. Come on, way back! It is gone! A cramped slam of a radio voice of the Boston Red Sox, Joe Castiglione. I don't have a signature home run call because all the good ones would take it. Well, Alan going, going, going.
让我们考虑一个音乐之外的例子。来吧，回去！它走了！波士顿红袜队广播员Joe Castiglione的紧凑猛击。我没有标志性的本垒打呼喊，因为所有好的呼喊都会把它拿走。嗯，Alan，去吧，去吧，去吧。
Going, going, going. Bye-bye, baby. Russ Hodges. Bye-bye, baby. At times, I've used forget about it because you know it's gone. Some fans didn't like this. We don't forget about it.
去吧，去吧，去吧。再见，宝贝。Russ Hodges。再见，宝贝。有时，我用“忘掉它吧”，因为你知道它走了。一些球迷不喜欢这个。我们不忘掉它。
It's a big home run. This isn't the number one fight that goes it. The role of broadcaster is to describe what you see and what is happening as it happens. That's why we broadcast in the present tense. It's my ideal and it's in there for a call strike. You can't be too soon anticipate because you can get burned that way. Sometimes the ball doesn't carry as far as you think it's going through or sometimes it carries farther. You can always tell if a broadcash is behind the action. If the crowd's cheering and you're still building up to what's happening, you have to be quick,
这是一个大本垒打。这不是第一个战斗。广播员的角色是描述你所看到的和正在发生的事情。这就是为什么我们用现在时广播。这是我的理想，它就在那里，为了一个好球。你不能太早预料，因为那样你可能会被烧伤。有时球并没有像你想象的那样飞得那么远，或者有时它飞得更远。你总是能看出广播是否落后于动作。如果人群在欢呼，而你还在为正在发生的事情做铺垫，你必须快，
you have to be current, you have to be right on time. Joe is such an important voice here in Boston. it used to be common practice to watch baseball games on TV, but with the sound off and the radio on. So we could watch the game, but listen to Joe. And then a strange thing happened. On June 12, 2009, Joe started calling the plays before we saw them on TV. That's because on that day, every TV station in the US switched from analog to digital transmission. And that lag in the digital television image,
你必须是当前的，你必须准时。Joe在波士顿是一个非常重要的声音。过去，在电视上观看棒球比赛，但关掉声音并打开收音机是一种常见的做法。这样我们就可以看比赛，但听Joe的解说。然后发生了一件奇怪的事情。2009年6月12日，Joe开始在我们在电视上看到之前就呼喊比赛。那是因为在那一天，美国所有的电视台都从模拟传输切换到了数字传输。而数字电视图像中的那种滞后，
the gap between it and the real time of the game as Joe was calling it, that is latency. It takes time for computers to translate the world into data and translating data to analog so we can perceive it, slows things down, enough to put the tag after the call by when you read it its history, when you hear it its news. And right ahead of this satellite picture on TV, so we are first. And I think the immediacy of radio is something that is so critical and so germane to it.
它与Joe正在呼喊的比赛实时之间的差距，那就是延迟。电脑需要时间将世界转化为数据，而将数据转化为模拟以便我们感知，这减慢了速度，足以在呼喊之后打上标签，当你读到它时，它是历史，当你听到它时，它是新闻。而在电视上的卫星画面之前，所以我们是第一。而且我认为广播的即时性是如此关键，如此切题。
Back before digital broadcast, that immediacy was audible in the city. You always knew when there was a home run at Fenway because you heard a simultaneous collective cheer all around Boston from every open window and passing call. Today those shouts are staggered. We get a splattering of cheers like scatter points on a graph. on a graph. That's because latency is different, slightly different, but different, on each digital device receiving its own particular stream of digital information. Professional music producers and engineers in the digital studio, worry about latency all the time. The lag it introduces can be very, very small, and yet it's always there, and always threatening
在数字广播之前，那种即时性在城市里是可听见的。你总是知道芬威球场什么时候有本垒打，因为你听到了波士顿各地从每一个打开的窗户和经过的汽车里传出的同时集体欢呼声。今天那些喊声是错开的。我们得到了一阵阵的欢呼，就像图表上的散点一样。那是因为延迟在接收其特定数字信息流的每个数字设备上是不同的，略有不同，但不同。数字录音室里的专业音乐制作人和工程师一直担心延迟。它引入的滞后可能非常、非常小，但它总是存在，并且总是威胁着
to knock the different layers of a song out of sync with one another. If a young drummer today manages to cast a wide net around the beat, perhaps that's not so different from my own speeding up and slowing down on Galaxy 500 recordings. It may be a flaw or it may be part of the charm. Yet there's something very distinct about an experience of analog time, time that flexes slower and quicker. Tempo Rubato and this feeling of blurred time from latency. For one, I can't think of a musical term for latency, perhaps because it's not like anything we experience in lived time.
将歌曲的不同层相互脱节。如果今天的一个年轻鼓手设法在节拍周围撒下一张大网，也许这与我在Galaxy 500录音中的加速和减速并没有什么不同。这可能是一个缺陷，也可能是魅力的一部分。然而，模拟时间的体验有一些非常独特的东西，时间会变慢和变快。Tempo Rubato和这种来自延迟的模糊时间感。首先，我想不出一个关于延迟的音乐术语，也许是因为它不像我们在生活时间中体验到的任何东西。
However, this experience of latency is typical of life online. For all our seemingly instant and global digital communications, life online is in practice filled with chronological confusions. Social media like Facebook and Twitter, shuffle posts, according to various algorithms, most obviously popularity. The net result being that yesterday's news bulletin can interrupt today's string of think pieces about it. Texting too is often tripped up by cross-posts, or mist posts, or abrupt silences, followed
然而，这种延迟体验是网络生活的典型特征。尽管我们有看似即时和全球性的数字通信，但网络生活在实践中充满了时间上的混乱。像Facebook和Twitter这样的社交媒体，根据各种算法（最明显的是受欢迎程度）洗牌帖子。净结果是，昨天的简报可以打断今天关于它的一连串思考文章。发短信也经常被交叉帖子、错过的帖子或突然的沉默所绊倒，随后
by ten beings in a row. Temporal hiccups and information exchange that would never happen face to face. In conversation, in real analog time, we can gauge reaction to our statements before anything further is said. We can pause without lapsing into silence, and we can fall silent without ending the conversation. Digital time is time designed for machines. We benefit in all kinds of ways from the convenience that makes possible. But those conveniences come at a sacrifice. Because when we trade broadcast for podcast, we give up the opportunity to experience time
是连续十个叮当声。信息交换中的时间性打嗝，这在面对面时永远不会发生。在对话中，在真实的模拟时间里，我们可以在说出任何进一步的话之前衡量对我们陈述的反应。我们可以暂停而不陷入沉默，我们可以保持沉默而不结束对话。数字时间是为机器设计的时间。我们从它所带来的便利中以各种方式受益。但这些便利是以牺牲为代价的。因为当我们用播客交易广播时，我们放弃了通过我们的媒体在同一瞬间一起体验时间的机会。
together in the same instant through our media. And when we trade real-time for machine-time in music, we lose the ability to share our individual timing with one another. Musicians use rubato, swing, and groove to move us together, not locked to a machine, but to one another. Analog time is flexible but unified. We share it so easily, without tinkering with technology, without even thinking about it. Maybe that's why we seem to be surrendering it so quickly. But without it, it's harder to share a moment
当我们用机器时间交易实时时间时，我们失去了与彼此分享我们个人时间的能力。音乐家使用rubato、swing和groove来推动我们在一起，不是锁定在机器上，而是锁定在彼此身上。模拟时间是灵活但统一的。我们如此容易地分享它，无需摆弄技术，甚至无需思考它。也许这就是为什么我们似乎放弃得如此之快。但没有它，就更难分享一个时刻
in tone together. Like those moments I once shared with my bandmates in a recording studio, in a particular place at a particular time on West Broadway just south of canal in New York City, 1988. This is Ways of Hearing. In the next episode, I'll take a trip to today's New York and look at the effect of digital sound on a perception of Showcase from Radio Topia and PRX, produced by me, Damon Krueckowski, Max Larkin and Ian Koss, with sound designed by Ian Koss. Thanks to Julie Shapiro and Alex Braunstein, recorded at the PRX Podcast Garage in Austin Mass. Our theme song is Trichle Down by Robert Wyatt.
在音调上在一起。就像我曾经在录音室里与我的乐队成员分享的那些时刻，在1988年纽约市运河街以南的西百老汇的一个特定地点和特定时间。这是《Ways of Hearing》。在下一集中，我将去今天的纽约，看看数字声音对感知的影响。来自RadioTopia和PRX的《Showcase》，由我、Damon Krueckowski、Max Larkin和Ian Koss制作，声音设计由Ian Koss负责。感谢Julie Shapiro和Alex Braunstein，在马萨诸塞州奥斯汀的PRX Podcast Garage录制。我们的主题曲是Robert Wyatt的《Trichle Down》。
Find out more about Ways of Hearing at radiotopia.fm slash showcase. I've been your witness. This series, Ways of Hearing, reminded me of one of my favorite and the night of the I episode about music and design. And if you're one of the people who never go through the back catalog, I thought I'd just present it to you here. It's short and fun. But first, I should pay some bills because thanks to these fun sponsors, we're allowed
在radiotopia.fm/showcase上了解更多关于《Ways of Hearing》的信息。我一直是你的见证人。这个系列，《Ways of Hearing》，让我想起了我最喜欢的关于音乐和设计的《99% Invisible》剧集之一。如果你是那些从不看后台目录的人之一，我想我只是在这里把它呈现给你。它简短而有趣。但首先，我应该付账单，因为多亏了这些有趣的赞助商，我们才被允许
to listen to all this for free. So this is a very old 9-9-PI and you can tell because I sound very young and much less exhausted, but it's an all-time favorite so I had to share. Enjoy. Gertis said that architecture is frozen music. That's lovely. Of course, that was before audio recording, so now for the most part. Music is frozen music. It's only very recently in the history of music that we've been able to freeze music into
免费收听所有这些。所以这是一个非常古老的9-9-PI，你可以看出来，因为我的声音听起来很年轻，而且没那么疲惫，但它是有史以来最受欢迎的，所以我必须分享。享受。歌德说建筑是凝固的音乐。那很可爱。当然，那是在录音之前，所以现在在很大程度上。音乐是凝固的音乐。在音乐史上，我们能够将音乐凝固成
an object. And in my life, the form of this object mattered a lot. I once bought vinyl albums and cassette tapes, and there were two first songs per album, Side A and Side B. The energy of a first song made it stand apart from the other songs, at least in my head at it. Then the CD came along and eliminated Side B and there was only one first song, and the actual number of the track that you can see prominently displayed on the CD player U.I.
一个物体是非常近期的事。而在我的生活中，这个物体的形式非常重要。我曾经买过黑胶唱片和盒式磁带，每张专辑有两首第一首歌，A面和B面。第一首歌的能量使它在其他歌曲中脱颖而出，至少在我的脑海里是这样。然后CD出现了，消除了B面，只有一首第一首歌，以及你在CD播放器UI上可以看到的显眼显示的实际曲目编号。
That became my index for sorting songs. Then MP3s jumbled my sense of track order and albums began to feel more like a loose group being of individual pieces rather than a conceptual hole. I could do this all day and you're welcome to chime in. Let's just let's totally hash this out on the website. But my point is this, when it comes to music the form of the thing matters. But no effect has been as world-, as the original innovation, freezing music in time onto a recording, where a single version of a song, a single performance of a song, became the song.
那成了我整理歌曲的索引。然后MP3打乱了我对曲目顺序的感觉，专辑开始感觉更像是一组松散的个人作品，而不是一个概念整体。我可以整天这样做，欢迎你们加入。让我们在网站上彻底讨论一下。但我的观点是，当谈到音乐时，事物的形式很重要。但没有任何影响像最初的创新那样，将音乐冻结在时间里录制下来，其中一首歌的单一版本，一首歌的单一表演，成为了这首歌。
This inherently mutable method of communication was fundamentally changed. Songs are astonishing things and I also don't think most people really even know what they are. That's the songwriter composer, Ampereiser John Bryant. Now I didn't talk to John Bryant, but I know people who did. Jim DeRigadas and Greg Cot are the hosts of a radio program I'm a huge fan of, called Sound Opinions. It's a rock and roll talk show. And if certain niche-y, snarky corners of the internet have darkened your concept of music journalism, well, Sound Opinions is your beacon of light, my friends.
这种本质上可变的交流方式被从根本上改变了。歌曲是令人惊奇的东西，我也不认为大多数人真的知道它们是什么。那是词曲作者、作曲家、编曲家John Bryant。现在我没有和John Bryant交谈，但我认识交谈过的人。Jim DeRigadas和Greg Cot是我非常喜欢的广播节目《Sound Opinions》的主持人。这是一个摇滚脱口秀。如果互联网上某些小众、刻薄的角落已经让你对音乐新闻的概念变暗了，那么，《Sound Opinions》就是你的指路明灯，我的朋友们。
Anyway, John Bryan came to WBZ in Chicago to talk to Sound Opinions in 2006. And at the time, Bryan had just co-produced Kanye West's album Late Registration, and he was also already well known as a film composer of a lot of really great movies, many by Paul Thomas Anderson. I heard the show broadcast on WBZ while I was sitting in my car and a parking lot of Atakaria and Logan Square, and I've thought about this section of their interview about songs versus performances, at least once a month since then.
无论如何，John Bryan于2006年来到芝加哥的WBZ与《Sound Opinions》交谈。当时，Bryan刚刚联合制作了Kanye West的专辑《Late Registration》，而且他作为许多非常棒的电影的电影作曲家也已经广为人知，其中许多是由Paul Thomas Anderson执导的。当我在Logan Square的一家Taqueria的停车场坐在车里时，我在WBZ上听到了这个节目的广播，从那时起，我每个月至少会想到他们采访中关于歌曲与表演的这一部分一次。
For six years, but only recently did it on me that this is a perfect 99% invisible story. So here it is. John Bryant on Sound Opinions in 2006. I distinguish between what for lack of better, I call songs and performance pieces. And what most people like are specific performances. We've grown up in an era of recording. And you know, the very thing, one of the very things I love recording has killed people's ability to hear songs purely as core change, melody and lyric.
六年来，但直到最近我才意识到这是一个完美的《99% Invisible》故事。所以这就是它。2006年《Sound Opinions》上的John Bryant。我区分了什么，因为缺乏更好的词，我称之为歌曲和表演作品。而大多数人喜欢的是特定的表演。我们在录音时代长大。而且你知道，我热爱录音的其中一件事，杀死了人们将歌曲纯粹作为和弦变化、旋律和歌词来听的能力。
It's a very strange and beautiful art form because when it's right, boy do you know it. But what we have sort of lost is, I don't know, the best example I could probably give would be Led Zeppelin. Those things are the ultimate performance pieces, and I'm a big fan. I think they're just absolutely astonishing and
这是一种非常奇怪和美丽的艺术形式，因为当它正确时，天哪，你知道它。但我们某种程度上失去的是，我不知道，我能给出的最好的例子可能是Led Zeppelin。那些东西是终极的表演作品，我是个大粉丝。我认为它们绝对令人惊叹，而且
the sort of dynamics they had are sorely lacking in music today. Record making is great. A true band in the sense that you really could tell who the individuals were. Remarkable thing. And I don't consider most of those things songs. And the way I can sort of prove my point is, have you ever listened to anybody else play Led Zeppelin song and gone, oh, that was a great satisfying experience. Except for Dread Zeppelin, who I'd love.
他们拥有的那种动态在今天的音乐中严重缺乏。唱片制作很棒。一个真正的乐队，在这个意义上，你真的能分辨出谁是个人。了不起的事情。而且我不认为大多数那些东西是歌曲。我证明我观点的方式是，你有没有听过别人演奏Led Zeppelin的歌，然后觉得，哦，那是一次很棒、令人满意的体验。除了Dread Zeppelin，我喜欢他们。
What people like is that specific guitar sound, that specific performance in concert with that specific drum sound, with that specific drummer playing that specific part, and it's beautiful. It's a beautiful thing. There are all different types of art and creative expression. However, if I were to sit and go here over on the piano and go, this is the melody to a lead sepulence off. And I could play, you know, 30 others, that's the thing. You know, I know it could sound like a snobbishness, it's not. I'm telling you, I love these records. Sure.
人们喜欢的是那种特定的吉他声音，那种特定的表演，与那种特定的鼓声，与那个特定的鼓手演奏那个特定的部分，它是美丽的。这是一件美丽的事情。有各种不同类型的艺术和创造性表达。然而，如果我坐下来，在钢琴上弹奏，说，这是Led Zeppelin歌曲的旋律。我可以弹奏，你知道，其他30首，就是这样。你知道，我知道这听起来可能像势利，但不是。我告诉你，我喜欢这些唱片。当然。
They're great. However, there's a difference between that and a song, say, a Gershwin song, you could actually play in the style of Led Zeppelin and have a completely satisfying experience. I do it all the time. I want to hear that. But when you start playing Zeephyl and the style of like 1920s music, it suddenly, it's laid bare that it's like, oh no, it was about those people
它们很棒。然而，那和一首歌之间是有区别的，比如，一首Gershwin的歌，你实际上可以用Led Zeppelin的风格演奏，并获得完全令人满意的体验。我一直这样做。我想听那个。但当你开始用20世纪20年代音乐的风格演奏Zeppelin时，它突然变得赤裸裸，就像，哦不，它是关于那些人
and those people were in a room and it was great. And I love it, but I consider it a performance piece. And I consider a lot of rock the people listen to be performance pieces. They're not necessarily songs. I heard you had Tom York here recently, and there's a guy who's a songwriter. Comes into the band and goes, here's the thing I've got, and then they rock with holy hardness and all the greatness they've got with them getting in a row. That's part of what makes a band like Radiohead stand out. When that second record came out, we all collectively went, oh my god!
而那些人在一个房间里，这很棒。我喜欢它，但我认为它是一件表演作品。而且我认为人们听的很多摇滚乐都是表演作品。它们不一定是歌曲。我听说你最近请了Tom York，那是一个词曲作者。来到乐队说，这是我有的东西，然后他们以神圣的坚韧和他们拥有的所有伟大之处摇滚起来。这就是让Radiohead这样的乐队脱颖而出的部分原因。当第二张唱片出来时，我们集体说，哦，天哪！
Somebody who actually has songs in this guy's an amazing singer. It isn't extinct yet. Yeah, and... Or Cobain, right? Right, exactly. And I mean, okay, here. Let's uh... The little musicology course?
一个真正有歌曲的人，这家伙是个了不起的歌手。它还没有灭绝。是的，而且……或者Cobain，对吧？对，完全正确。我的意思是，好吧，这里。让我们……那个小音乐学课程？
Okay, if you just go, yeah, it was cool. It was, you know, punk rock. It was popular. He had it factor for days. But if you take the average punk rock song, it is that same lead Zeppelin Meldy, even though they hated Zeppelin so much. You know, but bet it's like... You beat, you know, one of a thousand punk songs. Sure. There's a big difference between that and... I mean, I can sit here on Grand Piano, play an unaffected version and we can all go, oh my god, yeah, that's the best thing ever. Yeah, my spine tingles anytime. I play that melody over those chord changes That to me lithium is no
好吧，如果你只是说，是的，它很酷。它是，你知道，朋克摇滚。它很受欢迎。他有几天的因素。但如果你拿普通的朋克摇滚歌曲，它就是那个Led Zeppelin的旋律，尽管他们非常讨厌Zeppelin。你知道，但打赌它就像……你打赌，你知道，一千首朋克歌曲中的一首。当然。那和……之间有很大的区别。我的意思是，我可以坐在大钢琴上，弹奏一个未受影响的版本，我们都可以说，哦，天哪，是的，那是最好的东西。是的，我弹奏那些和弦变化上的旋律时，我的脊椎总是会发麻，对我来说，Lithium不是
Different it's in the same realm is being able to go, you know You know, where, you know, probably like most people, I remember exactly where I was first time I heard lithium. I remember back of the friends car and it came on and I just freaked out. I mean, I was nearly in tears. I'm like, oh my God, that guy is better than everybody's. Yeah, that's true. Yeah. Oh my God, that guy's better than everybody's life. Yeah, that's true. Yeah, it was so palpable.
虽然不同，但属于同一个领域，就是那种感觉，你知道的，就像大多数人一样，我清楚地记得第一次听到《Lithium》时我在哪里。我记得是在朋友的车后座，当这首歌响起时，我简直惊呆了。我的意思是，我当时差点流下眼泪。我想，天哪，那个家伙比所有人都强。是的，那是真的。是的。天哪，那个家伙比所有人的生活都强。是的，那是真的。是的，那种感觉太强烈了。
Like, that's one of the best core changes I've ever heard. It's absolutely as good as, you know, Gershwin or Thelonius Monk or any great thing that's existed. That was John Bryan talking with Jim DeRigadas and Greg Cot on Sound Opinions in 2006. Sound Opinions is produced by WBEZ Chicago and distributed by PRX. Find out more at soundopinions.org. 99% of visible is Katie Mingle, Planey Hall, Sharif Usif, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kirk Cole Stead, Avery Truffleman, Terran Mazza, Sean Riel, and me, Roman Mars.
那是我听过的最好的和弦变化之一。它绝对和格什温、塞隆尼斯·蒙克或任何伟大的作品一样出色。那是约翰·布莱恩在2006年的《Sound Opinions》节目中与吉姆·德罗加达斯和格雷格·科特交谈。 《Sound Opinions》由芝加哥WBEZ制作，并由PRX发行。更多信息请访问soundopinions.org。《99% Invisible》的制作团队包括凯蒂·明格尔、普莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·尤西夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、柯克·科尔·斯特德、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、泰兰·马扎、肖恩·里尔，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。
We are a project of K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and Coin Carrying listeners. Just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org or an Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too.
我们是旧金山KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样慷慨解囊的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上找到我们。
But our fabulous home on the internet with more design stories than we can ever manage to tell you here on the podcast is our website, 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们在互联网上精彩的家，拥有比我们在播客中能讲述的更多的设计故事，那就是我们的网站99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。